[음악]
네 안녕 사입니다 저희가 해외부동산
투자 세미나를 오늘 하는데 씨가
굉장히 좋네요 되게 많은 분들이
접수를 하셨더라고요 심지어 한 달
전에 마감이 돼 가지고 130명 정도
모집을 했는데 이렇게 빨리 마감이
될지 몰랐습니다 해외부동산에 관심이
많이 있다라는 생각을 좀 많이 하게
됐고 오늘 제가 진행을 하게 됐는데
잘할 수 있겠죠 안녕하세요 뉴욕에서
온 박 진우라이팅
를 하려고 하시는지 주거용 부동산과
상업용 부동산의 현재 상황 투자를
하신다고 하시면 어떤 부분들을
중점적으로 보셔야 하는지에 대해서
전반적으로 이야기를 드려볼까 합니다
그럼 시작하겠습니다 안녕하세요 오늘
그 해외 부동산투자 세미나 주간
주체한 bsn 수입입니다
반갑습니다네 오늘 세미나에 참석해
주셔서 감사합니다 첫 번째
강의는네 부동산 투자
관련해서 너스의 박진우 부사장님이
강의가 있겠습니다 안녕하세요 저
맨하튼에서 상업용과 주고 부동산
관계된 일을 한 20년 정도 해오고
있는 박 진우라이팅
[박수]
[음악]
저는 오늘 세미나에서 이제 미국
부동산 이제 절세 전략이라는 아주
무거운 주제를 가지고 왔는데 사실은
이제 미국부동산 저는 이제 세미나를
많이 다니다 보니까 이제 고객분들 좀
궁금해하시는 포인트를 잡아서 좀
준비를 해 봤어요 그리고 이제 가장
좀 궁금해하시는 부분 중에 하나가
미국 부동산을 이제 취득하셨습니다 때
이제 어떻게 구매를 하실 거에 대한
전반적인 뭐
구조적으로 어떻게 하시는게 좀 더
유리하실 이제를 전반적으로 좀 다루
드릴 거고요 어 문재원 세무사님
덕분에 이렇게 좋은 그 행사에 같이
참여할 수 있게 돼서 너무 영광이고요
앞으로도 불러주시면 언제든지
달려오겠지 인사드리겠습니다 저는
유텍스 하늘
회사입니다 어 자금 출처 확인 그런
것들도 너무
[음악]
중요해서 안녕하세요 전 문재 무사라고
하고요네 사남의 구독자
애청자로서이 이번 강의를 하게 돼서
너무 영광이라고 생각합니다 최근에
미국 부동산 투자를 많이 하시고자
하는 고객분들이 워낙 많으신데 저는
이제 한국 세법 그래도 조금 미국
세법과 연관을 해서 어떻게 준비하는게
좋은지 저도 마찬가지 무거운 주제를
가지고 왔기 때문에 하나름 회계사님
이제 미국쪽에 조금 초점 맞춰서
설명해 주실 것 같고 저는 이제
아무래도 한국쪽 관련돼서 설명을
드리는 거 위주로 세미나를 하기
위해서 왔습니다 잘
부탁드리겠습니다 안녕하세요 반동
소개받 문재 사입니다
반갑습니다 제가 그대 이민의 시대대
자산의 시대라고 해서 한 지금
준비한게 한 100장 정도 되거든요
제가 한 40분 할당 받았으니까 오늘
빠르게 갈게요네 상속세 걱정할 건
아닌데 대략 한번 상황
[음악]
볼게요 부동산이 어느 시점에 있는지에
대한 현황과 일본 내에서 보는 일본
부동산도 있지만은 외부에서 보는 일본
부동산도 어떻게 보이는지 그런
부분들을 저희가 준비를 하였고 실제
수요와 공급이 어떻게 이루어지고
있는지 그리고 현재 투자한 분들의
실제 성약 사례나 투자한 계기에
대해서 내용을 준비하겠습니다
안녕하세요 처음 인사드리겠습니다 저는
주리얼 에스테이트의 조 민수라 합니다
잘 탁드리겠습니다
도입이 되어
[음악]
있고요 아 예 안녕하세요 어 신한은행
부동산 투자자문 센터 양정
팀장입니다네 이세상으로 어 해외부동산
투자 세미나 강연을 마치도록
하겠습니다네 올랜 시간 강의 들어주
감사합니다
감사합니다 투자 세미나가 좀 쳤습니다
생각보다 관심이 많아서 놀랐고 되게
질문 수준도 너무 좋았고 아마
하반기에 또 하지 않을까 싶은데 좀
오늘 느낀 점이 되게 많아요 사실
이게 계획하게 된게 올해 1월 달에
좀 계획을 했는데 생각보다 되게 많은
분들이 또 이렇게 신청해 주셔 가지고
되게 놀랬고 관심이 많다라고 좀 많이
느꼈기 때문에 어 이번을 계기로
앞으로 좀 정기적으로 해볼
예정입니다네 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 다음 시간에
뵙겠습니다
감사합니다 잡지가 또 최근에
나왔거든요 그래서 잡지도 좀 선물로
드리고 있습니다 잡지가 좀 생각보다
되게 좀 힙하게 나왔고 되게 많은
분들한테 보여 드리고 싶지만
한정판으로 좀 나왔거든요 그래서 아마
다음 부부터 이제 서점에서도 판매할
예정인데 혹시 만약에 영상 보시는 분
중에 생각이 있다라고 하시는 분이
계시면 댓글 남겨 주시면 제가 한
다섯 분한테는 선물로 보내 드리도록
하겠습니다 많은 댓글 남겨 주시면
좋을 것
같습니다
e